why do you love president trump  well he's honest he's the biggest liar  in the history of american presidents  undeniable fact he's a christian he's  obviously not a christian he doesn't  know anything about the bible he didn't  go to church he concocted that to trick  people like this woman and it worked  that's why he did it because it worked  the proof is in the pudding this woman  believed it um anti-abortion he's not  anti-abortion he was in favor of choice  until he was 68 he decided to run and  said i got to come up with some story  about why i'm against abortion and he  came up with i met a kid i liked and the  mom told me she once thought about an  abortion and from that day forward i was  and that happened when he was 68.  they've fallen for all of it  and he calls it like it is he says what  all of us are thinking if we're all  thinking the things trump says we're  screwed we're really screwed